lcf
vive la chine en français jean marc
jancovici vous êtes associés pour
carbone 4 1 et président de chief
project un film thanks spécialisée dans
la transition carbone est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus sur ses
activités
alors tout ce qui tourne autour du
changement climatique et la transition
énergétique occupe ma vie
professionnelle et associative depuis
maintenant une quinzaine d'années
carbone 4 est une société qui s'occupe
de transition énergétique c'est-à-dire
qu'elle regarde pour les entreprises
clientes
où sont les risques à rester comme elle
est actuellement et les opportunités
si elle a envie de faire différemment
dechy project est un est un think tank
donc qui fait ce que les anglais
appellent ray de l'avocat si c'est à
dire que c'est une entité qui milite
pour la décarbonation de l'économie dit
autrement de chief project milite pour
que les activités productives des hommes
deviennent de plus en plus indépendante
des combustibles fossiles à la fois pour
des questions climat parce que si on
utilise trop de combustibles fossiles
ont fait courir des risques à l'humanité
au travers d'une modification climatique
qu'elle ne sera pas capable de gérer
dans de bonnes conditions et également
pour des questions d'approvisionnement
énergétique puisque il y à déjà sur
terre des zones dont l'europe qui sont
sous stress d'approvisionnement de
combustibles fossiles et donc rester
dépendante ces combustibles fossiles
c'est en gros ce condamné à enchaîner
les récessions les unes derrière les
autres et avoir son destin vous échapper
un peu plus chaque jour donc deux
activités qui finalement tour d'un petit
peu autour d'eux des mêmes questions
c'est à dire justement ce que vous venez
d'appeler la décarbonation de l'économie
c'est bien enfin absolument carbone 4 en
gros c'est la facette commercial de la
faire je prends un acteur et je réponds
à la question qui l'intéressent lui de
she project c'est je prends la société
dans son ensemble et je réponds aux
questions qui intéressent la société
dans son ensemble des corps des chiffres
project donc ça veut dire shift et c'est
à dire transformer un projet de
transformation
comment ça fonctionne alors quelles sont
les solutions que vous proposez pour
transformer l'économie transformer
l'économie
on le sait depuis très longtemps ça fait
à la fois des gagnants et des perdants
s'ils ont des carbones l'économie les
gens qui vendent des centrales à charbon
seront pas contents les gens qui vendent
des voitures pour partie seront pas
contents les gens qui vendent des
chaudières à fuel seront pas contents
les gens qui vendent des usines pour
faire de la matière plastique avec du
pétrole seront pas contents tout cas un
certain nombre de gens qui perdent
et puis il ya un certain nombre de gens
qui gagnent alors par exemple les gens
qui vendent des isolants pour les
bâtiments ils sont contents les gens qui
vendent des vélos ils sont contents les
gens qui vendent des trains ils peuvent
être contents pas toujours mais ils
peuvent être contents les gens qui
vendent de quoi faire soi même ses
conserves
ils sont contents enfin bref si vous
avez un certain nombre de gens qui sont
contents par delà les sempiternel
fabricant d'éoliennes et de panneaux
solaires auquel on n'échappe jamais
quand on parle de gens le sujet quand on
en reparlera plus tard des énergies
renouvelables comment ça fonctionne
alors vos comptes quels conseils vous
leur donnez pour pour pour devancer par
exemple oui donc donc pour finir sur la
présentation de deux chiffres alors
comme à l'âge que j'ai j'ai fini d'être
naïf
en gros si on veut que les choses
avancent il faut s'appuyer sur ceux qui
vont être contents et essayer de faire
en sorte que ceux qui seront pas
contents on les entend le moins possible
et donc on essaye au sein du chiffre de
faire quelque chose qui est très cynique
qui est de faire le lobby de ceux qui
sont contents donc aujourd'hui un
exemple vous pouvez nous donner un petit
exemple alors dans les membres
fondateurs du chiffre on va trouver par
exemple bouygues donc dont l'activité de
réhabilitation de locaux pourraient être
grandement favorisé dans un monde qui
s'occupent sérieusement de la contrainte
carbone en trouve la sncf trouver des f
trouve saint gobain on touche n'aidèrent
donc on trouve des gens qui ont intérêt
à ce qu'on mette une contrainte
croissante sur l'utilisation des
combustibles fossiles mais qui sont
dépollués à tout le monde et pas leur la
vie paulus et on ne sait pas enfin gros
pollueurs alors ça dépend certains oui
certains noms et puis par ailleurs dans
cette affaire vous avez deux voix que
vous pouvez choisir la première c'est la
suppression du pêcheur donc quelqu'un a
fait quelque chose de pas bien et votre
combat et de le supprimer
une deuxième voie qui est celle qu'on a
choisi c'est la rédemption du pêcheur
c'est à dire que les pêcheurs sont
tellement nombreux sur terre puisque
vous avez 7 milliards d'êtres humains
qui polluent tous
plus ou moins et en particulier deux
milliards d'êtres humains qui polluent
déjà beaucoup et beaucoup trop pour que
la situation reste en l'état
s'assumer les pays développés oui et
puis même les classes moyennes chinoises
sont déjà dans ce cadre là donc en gros
sel et les émissions par tête en france
sont les mêmes que les émissions par
tête en chine donc ce qu'on a appelé
pendant un temps les pays en voie de
développement où les pays émergents ils
ont parfaitement émerger merci ils sont
déjà un niveau qui est excessif par
rapport à ce qu'il faudrait avoir pour
garder un climat stable donc deux
milliards de personnes ça fait quand
même beaucoup à supprimer donc on va
plutôt essayer de viser la rédemption du
pêcheur plutôt que la suppression donc
pour les entreprises c'est par allister
que si on veut supprimer toutes les
entreprises qui sont de près ou de loin
dépendante des combustibles fossiles
aujourd'hui vous supprimez à peu près
tout donc le but du jeu c'est de
s'appuyer sur des gens qu'on globalement
intérêts qui bien globalement intéresse
pas dire qu'ils font pas par ailleurs
des choses qui sont pas terribles pour
essayer de faire progresser la cause
parce que l'idée c'est que ces gens là
où un porte voix qui est beaucoup plus
important que celui d'un individu de
pardon d'un individu et donc si je
commence à être convaincu que c'est dans
cette direction là qu'il faut aller pour
le bien de leurs propres affaires
ça fait un effet de levier sur la
décision publique qui sera beaucoup plus
fort que d'avoir simplement quelques
individus qui s'agitent et alors est ce
que vous arrivez à les convaincre
vous dites que c'est le cas pour des
grandes entreprises comme bouygues et df
mais quels sont les résultats de cette
action pour le moment en général alors
bord deux chiffres est un nouveau-né en
a 5 ans donc c'est aujourd'hui on a un
bilan qui est nécessairement à la mesure
de cette existence raisonnablement jeune
mais il ya déjà quelques petites choses
qu'on a réussi à faire passer alors il
se trouve que avant de créer le shift
j'ai travaillé avec nicolas hulot
pendant un certain nombre d'années et
j'ai notamment été coauteur du pacte
écologique et ce travail a eu un effet
direct dans la mise en place de la taxe
carbone en france
au sein du chiffre on a travaillé
beaucoup sur la question de la
réhabilitation du patrimoine bâti ce
qu'on appelle la rénovation thermique
des logements et on a contribué à ce que
dans la loi de transition il ya quelque
chose sur ce sujet-là sur en gros
l'obligation de faire un diagnostic de
tous les bâtiments puis une forme de
mise en conformité avec le temps au
roman l'obligation est très timide dans
la loi enfin c'est un début on a
contribué directement inspiré une des
mesures du plan juncker qui a été votée
au parlement européen il ya maintenant
quelques mois n'est qu'en qu'elle plomb
exactement c'est le grand plan
d'investissements de juncker qui veut en
gros faire une relance en europe par les
investissements et dans les mesures
importantes de ce plan il ya notamment
une mesure de réhabilitation du parc
public tertiaire tertiaire public comme
on veut donc tout ce qui est caserne de
gendarmerie hôpitaux etc
et là on a fait une proposition assez
fouillée qui a fini par trouver son
chemin jusqu'à la commission et qui a
inspiré directement une des mesures du
plan hincker on a également le discours
public d'un certain nombre d'entreprises
qui a été directement inspirée par
l'action qu'on a pu mener au shift ou
que les gens qui ont fini par se
retrouver au shift ont pu mener quand
ils n'étaient pas encore au shift parce
que tout ça procède d'une histoire
donc on commence à avoir quelques effets
observables de alors on a également
directement on a également été
partenaire du business and climate
summit qui a été organisée à paris
unesco voilà en mai dernier
nous sommes co initiateur donc co
fondateur quelque part du premier salon
mondial sur l'économie décarbonée qui va
se tenir à paris en octobre et qui
s'appellera world fish n 6 donc on
commence à avoir quelques réalisations à
notre actif
elle sait
mais si la chine en français
oh
lcf visite la chine en français
où
alors jean marc jancovici quand on parle
de changement climatique de quoi
parle-t-on exactement
sans vouloir être excessivement
catastrophiste mais quand même pour
utiliser un mot simple on parle de
recevoir éventuellement une claque d'une
ampleur dont on n'a pas idée
tout le monde a en tête cette différence
de quelques degrés de la moyenne
planétaire qui pourrait séparer
aujourd'hui de 2100 alors en général
quand on dit ça les gens ils ont pas
peur ils ont même ça les rassure presque
parce que quelques degrés c'est plus que
c'est - pardon que la différence de
température entre ce matin et cet après
midi
il dit ce qui fera plus beau est la
ligne exactement et ils mettront leurs
maillots de bain plutôt dans la plus tôt
dans l'année
et puis par ailleurs en 2100 serait mort
mes enfants seront morts et
petits-enfants sont pleines mort ou que
bon tout va bien on va aller s'occuper
de boucler les fins de mois d'abord et
ensuite on verra pour ça alors en fait
un élément fondamental qu'il faut avoir
en tête c'est de comprendre ce que
signifie quelques degrés de variation de
la moyenne planétaire quand on regarde
le passé et on a un précédent par en un
siècle
mais en dix mille ans c'est la dernière
déglaciation quand la terre est passé du
dernier maximum glaciaire sert le moment
où il faisait le plus froid de l'ère
quaternaire
il ya vingt mille ans au climat que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui est bien la
moyenne planétaire n'a augmenté que de 5
degrés et quand il faisait 5 degrés plus
froid le niveau de l'océan était plus
bas de 120 m les moyennes latitudes et
donc par exemple l'europe et une bonne
partie de la chine
ressembler au nord de la sibérie
actuelle vous aviez pas de scandinaves
parce qu'ils étaient sous la glace il y
avait une énorme calotte glaciaire qui
était posé sur toute la scandinavie et
sur le nord de l'ecosse et à cette
époque là tout ce que les moyennes tout
ce que la france était capable de
nourrir par exemple c'était 100 mille
bonshommes et la différence il n'y avait
pas de forêts en europe enfin donc la
différence entre ce paysage et celui
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui c'est juste 5
degrés de réchauffement de la moyenne
planétaire et c'est quelque chose qui
s'est passé en cinq à dix mille ans donc
0,1 degré par siècle
si on applique à une situation de départ
qui est celle que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui un réchauffement moyen de
même amplitude parce que l'attend la
variation de température dans la journée
a dit rien sur
moyenne la moyenne planétaire elle est
remarquablement stable à l'échelle du
siècle si l'on touche pas au climat rhin
donc appliqué au climat planétaire une
élévation de même amplitude en un siècle
c'est une déstabilisation d'une telle
ampleur que il va y avoir des problèmes
d'accès à l'alimentation d'accès à l'eau
d'accès aux ressources écosystémiques
n'y aura plus de bois ou plus de forêts
plus etc de dommages aux infrastructures
parce que l'élévation du niveau de la
mer ça va vous faire des katrina de plus
en plus fréquents ça va l'élévation de
la température ça va vous dilater les
caténaires dilater les lignes
électriques fissures et les bâtiments
etc
la succession des choses désagréables
qui vont se passer les migrations qui
s'en suivront tout ça va probablement
aboutir si on fait l'expérience jusqu'à
son terme ce que je ne souhaite pas un
monde qui redeviendra chaotique guerrier
violent pas démocratique du tout où on
se remette on verra apparaître des
régimes totalitaires un peu partout en
réponse à la contrainte et c'est pas
juste un problème de maillots de bain
mis un peu plus tôt dans l'année c'est
un problème de monde encore une fois
qu'on va créer qui sera beaucoup plus
désagréable que l'idée qu'on peut s'en
faire et donc c'est bien ça qu'il s'agit
d'éviter et alors tout ça du fait de la
présence de l'homme sur terre puisque
donc aujourd'hui plus personne ou
presque ne remet en question l'origine
anthropique de ces changements
climatiques
alors le climat a toujours variées ainsi
on regarde dans les îles a varié il ya
eu des airs glaciaire désert plus chaude
il ya probablement eu dans un passé très
lointain des moments où la terre était
presque quasiment totalement glacée
il ya eu aussi dans le passé lointain
des épisodes où la moyenne planétaire
était probablement 10 degrés plus élevée
qu'aujourd'hui donc à l'époque des
dinosaures par exemple donc le fait que
le climat est varié ça c'est quelque
chose de normal ce qui est en train de
se passer en ce moment c'est que l'homme
est en train de devenir le premier
facteur de changement climatique à
l'échelle du siècle et que ce changement
s'apprête à être beaucoup plus rapide
que ce que la nature sait faire tout
seul en termes de variation climatique
et c'est la rapidité
qui pose un vrai problème alors ce qui
est à l'origine de la faire c'est une
variation brusque de ce qu'on appelle
l'effet de serre en effet de serre est
quelque chose qui est parfaitement
naturel est présent sur terre depuis des
milliards d'années et qui est la
caractéristique qu'à l'atmosphère d'être
opaque au rayonnement infrarouge émis
par la terre qui protège finalement la
terre du des rayons du soleil d'or non
c'est dans l'autre sens que ça se passe
dans l'atmosphère il y a deux effets qui
sont distincts et qui nous intéresse il
ya un premier effet de protection qui
est liée à la couche d'ozone qui est
d'empêcher les rayons ultraviolets les
plus dur d'arriver jusqu'à la surface
terrestre et ça c'est quelque chose qui
nous intéresse beaucoup parce que s'il
n'y avait pas cette protection la vie
pourrait pas prendre place en gros les
ultraviolets dur détruirait les
molécules complexes qui permettent à la
vie d'exister on a par contre un autre
effet qui est un effet de type
couverture c'est-à-dire que l'opacité de
l'atmosphère au rayon infrarouge émis
par la surface parce que le sol chauffe
quand il reçoit la lumière du soleil et
donc il émet des infrarouges et il se
trouve que l'atmosphère à cause de la
présence de certains gaz en son sein et
aux pacsés infrarouge est historiquement
il ya eu une variation de cette opacité
alors l'essentiel du temps naturel
volcanisme l'a fait varier
et puis en ce moment c'est l'homme qui
est en train d'accroître cette opacité
en rajoutant très rapidement dans
l'atmosphère des gaz à effet de serre
qui sont des gaz qui s'en vont pas vite
en gros donc si on en avait beaucoup sur
un laps de temps court qu'on est en
train de faire mais ils restent là
longtemps avant de s'en aller
il est temps qu'il reste là eh bien ils
augmentent cette opacité aux infrarouges
et le fait que l'atmosphère soit plus
opaque aux infrarouges fait que ça
confine la chaleur près du sol donc
l'augmentation de l'effet de serre rend
la planète plus chaude près du sol soit
dit en passant ça refroidit en même
temps le haut de l'atmosphère
puisque la chaleur elle traverse moins
bien l'atmosphère donc on va dire c'est
plus chaud près du bas plus froid près
du haut et la vitesse à laquelle ça se
produit en ce moment est tel que ça va
causer des désordres en quantité
croissante dans la manière dont les
hommes sont organisées donc ça va faire
des surprises en quantité croissante les
trucs qu'on va pas aimer alors on disait
tout à l'heure que les climatosceptiques
était pratiquement inexistant
aujourd'hui enfin il existe toujours
qu'est ce qu'on peut leur répondre à ces
personnes qui doutent encore de ces
changements climatiques qui justement
qui constate que finalement le il fait
pas tellement plus chaud que quand on
était enfants ou que gilg il ya une
vingtaine d'années et que du coup ce que
disent les scientifiques finalement ça
n'a pas tellement de sens alors je vais
prendre un parallèle qui vaut ce qu'il
vaut vous êtes jeunes mariés très
amoureux ou très amoureuse et un de vos
meilleurs amis vient vous expliquer que
la veille il a eu votre conjoint dans
les bras de quelqu'un d'autre
une partie des gens vont pas avoir envie
d'y croire
t'es sûr ce n'était pas quelqu'un qui
lui ressemblait tu avais pas bu un verre
tu avais pas oublié tes lunettes chez
toi tu avais pas une poussière dans
l'oeil
bon donc pourquoi est ce que on a ce
genre de réaction parce que de temps en
temps on vous apprend des choses dont
les conclusions sont tellement
désagréable que vous préféreriez que le
fai ne soit pas valide corps donc il se
trouve votre ami a malheureusement très
bien vu mais vous n'avez vraiment pas
envie d'y croire donc vous allez essayer
de trouver toutes les raisons qui font
qu'ils pourraient avoir vu de travers
c'est exactement pareil en ce qui
concerne le climato-scepticisme c'est à
dire que l'essentiel même la tête
totalité des climato-sceptiques j'ai eu
à connaître par leurs écrits dans mon
existence sont des gens qui n'ont pas la
capacité de remettre en cause la science
qui va derrière la question du
changement climatique mais qui par
contre sont fondamentalement dérangé par
les conséquences et puis il ya des
intérêts économiques aussi derrière ça
fait partie des raisons d'être dérangé
oui alors le la première partie des
dérangés entre guillemets et c'est ce
qui domine aux états unis sont les gens
qui disent cette affaire-là
au fond c'est une manifestation du monde
fini si on accepte que c'est un vrai
problème
alors on accepte qu'il va falloir se
restreindre dans l'utilisation de
quelque chose
or vous savez que le slogan des états
unis depuis l'origine c'est no limits
donc l'idée même de la restriction est
quelque chose qui est absolument pas
dans le code génétique de la mentalité
américaine c'est un truc est
inenvisageable et la meilleure preuve de
la validité de cette explication c'est
que le changement climatique
d'origine anthropique est considéré
comme légitime par 81% des démocrates
c'est à dire les habitants des côtes
ceux qui sont ouverts sur le monde et
ceux qui habitent dans des villes qui
sont déjà gros c'est donc la contrainte
physique y voit déjà ce que c'est parce
que les habits les urbains en général
ils sentent plus la contrainte physique
a envie de l'espace est confiné on
respire pas bien la nourriture coûte
cher enfin bon bref donc la contrainte
physique on la voit déjà et les
républicains c'est à dire ceux du centre
les héritiers du far west
quelque part là où il n'y a pas de
limite là où et c'est à 10%
il accepte l'idée que le changement
climatique est d'origine anthropique la
différence est importante du viol entre
10 et 80 il faut dire que la différence
est donc le climato-scepticisme aux
états unis
c'est la marque d'une conviction
libérale qui est qu'il n'est pas
légitime qu'il y ait des limites à
l'activité humaine et une fois que vous
avez cette conviction profondément
chevillée au corps fait le chemin à
l'envers puisque vous voulez pas de
contrainte
et bien tout ce qui pourrait donner lieu
à une contrainte est nécessairement
invalide donc en particulier la science
du changement climatique est invalide le
les gens alors là où le grand public
devient perdu c'est que ces gens là
quand ils sont invités dans les médias
sont invités par des journalistes qui
n'ont pas la capacité technique de les
réfuter tout un journaliste qui n'est
pas scientifique il est pas payée pour
faire des recherches
d'accord je confirme donc c'est pas son
métier et donc en fait il se rend pas
compte qui vient d'inviter quelqu'un qui
s'exprime sur un terrain où il est pas
légitime
la seule bonne manière et je vais finir
par sa de remettre en cause la science
elle est très simple c'est une règle de
processus
si vous pensez par exemple que le
changement climatique est dû aux
variations d'activité du soleil
eh bien vous commencez par faire une
campagne de mesure qui permet de
détecter les variations du soleil
l'effet sur la température au sol de ses
variations du soleil et vous publier
dans une revue scientifique à comité de
lecture
ce que vous avez trouvé et en quoi ça
invalides une conclusion qui était
précédemment admise tant que vous n'avez
pas ça pas fait sa part dont vous est il
recevable à aller vous promener dans les
médias grand public en disant moi je
pense que hors pas un je dis bien pas un
climato sceptiques deux mois connus pas
un
na à l'appui de ce qu'il avance la
publication scientifique qui permettrait
de dire ce que je dis est fondée pas un
donc la raison pour laquelle le
climato-scepticisme existe c'est parce
que malheureusement dans le monde
médiatique on eu ce qu'on ne connaît pas
cette règle de processus
sinon on ferait très vite le tri entre
les gens qui sont légitimes et les gens
qui le sont pas et donc on inviterait
pas les climato sceptiques sur le thème
vous êtes capable de remettre en cause
la science on les inviterait sur le
thème la science vous déranger expliquez
moi pourquoi
et c'est tout le problème aussi de ces
questions de climat c'est que comme vous
le disiez à l'instant un journaliste
n'est pas seulement les journalistes
on ne sait pas très bien comment tout ça
fonctionne quand on n'est pas un
scientifique justement il est très
difficile de se faire une opinion et
lorsqu'un un climato sceptiques prend la
parole pourquoi ne pas justement
l'écouté au même titre que quelqu'un
d'autre on est d'accord
eh ben il faut malheureusement se
retrancher derrière une règle de
processus qui est la seule qui
garantissent la confiance pourquoi
est-ce que vous accepter l'idée que le
prof de votre enfant au collège soit
bien prof dans le collège parce qu'il ya
eu une règle de processus c'est qu'on
lui a fait passer un examen et que s'il
ne réussit pas l'examen il est pas prof
donc c'est pas vous en direct qui est
allé vérifier que les faire une addition
ou qui connaît correctement le
subjonctif
c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui s'en est
chargé et vous fait confiance à la règle
de processus qui globalement fonctionne
à peu près toujours les moments où ça
fonctionne pas mais globalement et
fonctionnaires soit c'est la meilleure
garantie que vous avez est bien dans la
science il ya aussi une règle de
processus et c'est la règle derrière
laquelle il faut se retrancher donc un
climato sceptiques qui veut prendre la
parole
la seule question à lui poser sait où
est la référence de la publication
scientifique qui vous permet de dire ça
tant qu'il n'est pas capable de répondre
à cette question c'est même pas la peine
de l'écouter sur la lcf
la chine en français
lcf la chine en français
jean marc jancovici on va maintenant on
parler des conséquences
des changements climatiques qu'elle
pourrait donc concrètement être ses
conséquences d'un point de vue humain et
du point de vue de la planète je pense
en particulier à la question des
déplacés une question qui nous touche
beaucoup
actuellement avec les événements récents
des migrants venus notamment de syrie
alors si on part de ce que physiquement
est le changement climatique
c'est à dire une augmentation de l'effet
de serre
c'est à dire une énergie qui a plus de
mal à s'échapper de la surface terrestre
il ya un certain nombre de choses qui
vont se produire et chacune est
susceptible d'avoir des effets positifs
en de rares endroits négatif l'essentiel
du temps pour la 1er le premier effet
c'est une élévation de la température
l'élévation de la température en tant
que tel peut avoir des effets par
exemple sur les dommages aux
infrastructures
vous avez des caténaires les caténaires
se dilater crack le train avance plus
vous avez des lignes électriques les
lignes électriques se dilate elle touche
le sol et craque ça prend feu c'est déjà
arrivé
un deuxième effet c'est que ça va
modifier le cycle de l'eau alors sur une
terre plus chaudes
globalement il ya plus d'eau qui
s'évapore faut quand même se rappeler
même si c'est par là qu'on habite que
les deux tiers de la planète sont
couverts d'eau donc si il fait plus
chaud plus d'eau s'évapore du coup il va
globalement pleuvoir plus mais ce plus
de précipitations va être plus mal
répartie là où aujourd'hui il pleut déjà
pas beaucoup il va pleuvoir encore -
notamment le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen et les tropiques et les
saisons sèches dans les pays de mousson
est là où il pleut beaucoup il va
pleuvoir encore plus donc il faut
s'attendre à avoir de plus en plus
souvent des inondations en angleterre
l'hiver des inondations en europe du
nord l'hiver et des moussons un peu
violente
d'accord mais pourquoi alors cette
répartition
parce que c'est comme ça que le système
fonctionne malheureusement rentrer dans
les détails un peu technique ça serait
compliqué donc le parce qu'on intensifie
en gros on intensifie la circulation
dans les cellules de hadley si vous
voulez tout savoir qui organise la
circulation à grande échelle de
l'atmosphère ils font que compliquer
c'est sec et l'équateur et les moyennes
latitudes et hautes latitudes c'est plus
humide d'accord le alors qu'est ce que
ça va me provoquer cette modification du
cycle de l'eau ça va sécheresse ça veut
dire que là où on est déjà limite pour
assurer la production agricole on sera
encore plus et là je peux faire un lien
direct par exemple avec le pourtour du
bassin méditerranéen qui est en train de
s'assécher sa conjugué au fait que de
temps en temps il ya des problèmes sur
les importations sarr a directement
déclenché le printemps a par exemple
vous avez ensuite d'autres endroits ou à
l'opposé le fait qu'ils fassent plus
humide et plus doux ça va intensifier
les ravageurs de toute nature qui vont
s'attaquer aux bois aux cultures dont
vous allez voir arriver des champignons
des moisissures d'aidé
de l'oïdium etc c'est déjà en train de
se passer aussi les insectes qui mange
le bois ou qu'ils mangent les cultures
seront pas tués l'hiver parce qu'il faut
pas assez froid liam vous allez ensuite
avoir une élévation du niveau de l'océan
l'élévation du niveau de l'océan va
rapprocher du bord de mer toutes les
infrastructures qui s'y trouvent ont
historiquement toutes les villes sont
implantés à côté de l'eau soit de la mer
soit d'une rivière
parce que c'était ça qui permettait
d'avoir du transport facile de produits
un peu massif les pierres pour la
construction éventuellement les céréales
etc
tant qu'on n'avait pas les routes et les
engins à moteur qui circulent dessus
donc regarder toutes les villes
anciennes ou qu'elles soient sont
traversés par un cours d'eau en europe
où sont au bord de la mer donc là alors
les inondations ça va concerner les
villes au bord d'un cours d'eau et la
hausse du niveau de la mer va concerner
les villes en bord de mer avec la
probabilité qui va augmenter que à la
faveur d'un tsunami qui n'a rien à voir
avec le changement climatique d'une
tempête qui peut ne rien avoir à voir
avec le changement climatique d'un
ouragan et c6 est plus près du bord de
mer vous allez augmenter les dégâts les
infrastructures de bord de mer gelée
plein de trucs qui sont vitaux les ports
une bonne partie des centrales
électriques par exemple toutes les
centrales électriques japonaises sont en
bordeaux parce qu'il faut une source
froide pour le refroidissement de la
centrale donc les centrales sont très
volontiers son style sont pas au bord de
mer elles sont en bord de rivière mais
elles sont volontiers abandonné 6 plus
commode pour l'acheminement du charbon
aussi vous avez ensuite dans les autres
dans les autres choses qui vont se
passer un dépérissement des écosystèmes
toujours à cause de sécheresse et où
inondations
une fois que je met tout ça bout à bout
ça veut dire que les gens les endroits
où il faut beaucoup il fait part dont
les endroits où il fait bon vivre et les
endroits où il fait pas bon vivre vont
se modifier
historiquement quand les gens étaient
nomades ce qui se passait à ce moment
c'est que les gens se déplaçaient qu'ils
allaient des endroits où il fait bon
mado picon et sédentaires le premier
réflexe est de s'adapter
là où on est toujours c'est quand même
compliqué de se déplacer avec ses ports
ses raffineries ces écoles et notre dame
de paris sur le dos préfère quand même
les laisser là où ils sont et ils
continuent à vivre à côté et essayer de
s'adapter mais ça ne tient qu'un temps
et modifier éventuellement
l'environnement ont d'ailleurs
intéressant parce que s'il n'y a plus
rien à manger
là où il ya notre dame de paris font
apparaître qu'on bouge et à ce moment
bouger pour aller où
et là vous avez que deux options ou bien
vous bouger pour aller là où il ya déjà
quelqu'un et le quelqu'un sera pas
content de vous voir arriver et ça va
être le problème des réfugiés
climatiques mais les réfugiés
climatiques si ça ce sera pour partie
nous hein faut pas croire que ça va
juste il est réfugié climatique à cause
de ce que je viens d'expliquer seront le
plus souvent des migrations de voisinage
alors on va dans la ville la plus proche
est en train de se passer en ce moment
avec les réfugiés syriens réfugiés
syriens ils partent pas aux états unis
ou au brésil où est ta ils vont à côté
alors à côté c'est le côté de la
méditerranée donc on va bouger pas très
loin de là où on est et s'il ya des gens
là où on arrive qu'ils sont pas contents
de le voir arriver ça va déclencher des
tensions et s'il ya personne là où on
arrive c'est qui a pas d'infrastructures
et dont il faut tout recommencer à zéro
et donc on repart au moyen-âge direct
donc dans un cas comme dans l'autre
cette affaire-là va créer des tensions
in fine et politiques sociales
économiques de toutes natures et après
il faut être qu'il faut lire dans le
marc de café ou avoir une bourde une
boule de cristal pour être capable de
prédire exactement ce qui peut se passer
enfin il ya des projections qui existent
on peut même voir des animations sur des
sites internet
sur lesquels on peut jouer à voir à quel
niveau la mère allait monter sur la
surface de la terre en fonction des
degré d'élévation de température alors
c'est en fonction des degrés et c'est en
fonction de l'échéance
parce que le la réponse de l'océan est
quelque chose qui va prendre beaucoup
plus de temps que la réponse de
l'atmosphère
parce que l'eau science une grande
baignoire une baignoire de 4 km de
profondeur
donc le temps que le supplément de
chaleur concret en surface se propage
dans toute la couche océanique
ça va prendre des milliers d'années or
ce qui fait monter le niveau de l'eau
c'est tout simplement le fait que l'eau
chaude se dilate enfin il peut occuper
plus de volume que l'eau froide
donc quand vous chauffer l'eau qui est
dans la grande baignoire océaniques
comme le font ils bougent pas et bien le
niveau de l'eau monte à loos dilate le
niveau de l'eau monte et le temps que la
vague de chaleur se propage jusqu'aux
fond de l'océan
ça va prendre des milliers d'années donc
pendant des milliers d'années le niveau
de l'eau va continuer à monter
donc quand on regarde où en sera le
niveau de la mer il faut préciser si ses
2100 2200 2300 3000 4000 5000 à
température idéale
oui même si la température ne bouge plus
le niveau de l'eau va continuer à monter
et il va continuer à monter pour une
deuxième raison c'est que on n'est pas
très loin d'avoir enclenché la fonte
irréversible du groenland
ça va prendre un millier d'années la
foule mais à l'arrivée c'est six mètres
dos en plus on a un risque également sur
une partie de l'antarctique qu'on
appelle la calotte antarctique de
l'ouest c'est aussi six mètres dos en
plus donc là on est en train de jouer
l'antarctique tout court
pour le moment on le voit pas bouger
mais on est quand même des gens en train
de prendre un risque sur dix à quinze
mètres d'élévation du niveau de l'océan
ont quelques siècles un millier d'années
donc évidemment vous serez pas la mort
non plus c'est encore plus loin que 2100
mais par contre les villes de bord de
mer qui sont là depuis des siècles des
millénaires on va pas les déménager en
une semaine
ni même
elle cff la chine en français
lcf et si la chine en français
jean marc jancovici quand on parle de
réchauffement climatique il faut bien
sûr parler de la question de l'énergie
et des ressources
tout d'abord est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire deux mots sur la question des coûts
de l'énergie
à combien évaluez ton ses coûts
aujourd'hui en quoi sont-ils un frein à
la croissance future finalement alors le
en fait le coût de l'énergie n'est pas
directement ce qui gêne ou pas la
croissance ce qui gêne ou pas la
croissance et le volume alors mais je
vais quand même commencer par parler du
coup alors je veux d'abord vous
surprendre en vous disant que l'énergie
est gratuite
c'est à dire toute l'énergie gratuite eh
bien vous savez que dans la dans le
discours écologiste on a coutume de dire
le soleil est gratuit effectivement
personne n'a rien payé pour que le
soleil brille mais personne n'a rien
payé non plus pour que le pétrole existe
les gisements de pétrole se sont formés
en quelques dizaines de millions
d'années avec des processus tout à fait
naturel pour lesquels il n'y a pas une
personne sur terre qui est payé le
moindre centime
par contre on le sait y à l'arrivée
disent oui mais le soleil aussi parce
que vous devez payer le travail des gens
qui vous fournissent le dispositif pour
récupérer l'énergie solaire balle
pétrole c'est pareil vous devez payer le
travail des gens qui vous fournissent le
dispositif pour récupérer le pétrole
et puis vous devez aussi payé un
propriétaire dans la sphère alors pour
le pétrole vous devez payer celui qui a
eu la chance d'être assis sur le tas de
pétrole exactement sur le gisement de
pétrole sur le tas de charbon mais en ce
qui concerne le soleil ou le vent par
exemple vous devez aussi payé le
propriétaire de l'endroit où vous allez
mettre le panneau solaire ou éolienne
donc dans tous les cas de figure vous
payez un propriétaire et vous payez du
travail et le fabricant de panneaux dont
vous ne payez que des hommes en fait
dans notre convention économique les
ressources naturelles sont gratuites
le patrimoine génétique des abeilles
existants personne et rien payer le
patrimoine génétique des chaînes
existent en personne et rien payé
l'océan existants personne n'ait rien
payer les moustiques existent
malheureusement sans que personne n'ait
rien payer ainsi que les souris qui
dérange un certain nombre de gens donc
tout ça existe sans qu'on n'ait rien
payé et de la même manière le pétrole le
charbon le gaz l'uranium
les chutes d'eau le vent
le soleil le bois qui brûle tout ça
existe sans qu'on n'ait rien payer donc
le coût de l'énergie ne reflètent qu'une
chose c'est la quantité de travail parce
qu'en fait payer s'est payé des hommes
c'est la quantité de travail et la
quantité de rente qu'il faut payer à
quelqu'un pour passer d'une énergie qui
est gratuite à l'énergie sortie de
l'environnement est mise à votre
disposition puisque l'énergie elle doit
déjà être dans l'environnement pour
qu'on puisse s'en servir
ça nous amène pas à grand chose et d'en
inventer l'énergie mal de voir une
rivière passés ou vont le sortir de
l'environnement or les sûr c'est de la
physique plus l'énergie dans
l'environnement elle est déjà présente
sous forme concentrée et facile à
extraire - il va vous falloir de travail
pour sortir un kilowattheure de
l'environnement et donc moi ça sera cher
donc quand on est historiquement qu'est
ce qui s'est passé on est passé des
énergies renouvelables le premier
énergies utilisées par les hommes ça a
été le bois de feu puis le vent qui a
fait avancer les premiers bateaux le
soleil qui a séché les premières
récoltes et c'est donc les énergies
renouvelables c'est les premières et les
seules qu'on est utilisé très longtemps
la traction animale baisse de ses taux
qu'à un jour on est passé au charbon
premières énergies non renouvelables
qu'on a utilisé de manière significative
même avant on avait utilisé
l'hydroélectricité en 1900 les chutes
d'eau
c'était le mode dominant de production
électrique alors on produisait beaucoup
moins d'électricité qu'aujourd'hui
centaines de fois moins mais c'est l
hydroélectricité quitter le mode
dominant de production où ça en france
on ne rencontre alors ailleurs qu'en
europe à l'époque la civilisation
industrielle ça existait pas trop donc
c'était en vraiment le mode dominant et
puis on est passé au charbon de manière
croissante et le charbon permet
d'extraire avec la même quantité de
travail plus de kilowattheures de
l'environnement parce que c'est déjà
présent sous forme plus concentré puis
ensuite on est passé au pétrole qui
représentera l'optimum historique auquel
les hommes ont eu accès
parce que c'est le plus dense
énergétiquement par litre c'est très
facile à extraire
c'est extrêmement facile à transporter
et à stocker parce que ces liquides et
c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est
l'énergie qui s'est imposé dans les
transports
parce que c'est l'énergie qu'il est le
plus facile à une machine d'emmener avec
elle quand elle se déplace
quand on est passé du pétrole au gaz on
est descendu d'un cran dans la densité
énergétique dans un litre de gas vous
avez mille fois moins d'énergie que dans
1 litre de pétrole
donc du coup le gaz c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué à transporter et à stocker que
le pétrole c'est pas plus compliqué à
extraire mais c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué à transporter et à stocker
c'est la raison pour laquelle le pétrole
est une énergie mondiale et le gaz est
une énergie régionales quand on passe du
gaz au nucléaire on perd encore un cran
dans la facilité d'emploi le nucléaire
c'est très concentré mais c'est
tellement concentré justement que ça
demande des grosses machines compliqué
pour pas faire de bêtises quand on s'en
sert
et quand on passe du nucléaire aux
énergies renouvelables pouet pouet
moderne qui est excitant le grand public
et les journalistes on perd encore un
cran dans la facilité de mise en oeuvre
parce qu'on accède à une énergie qui est
très diffuses l'air qui se déplacent
c'est pas beaucoup d'énergie et un mètre
carré ça récupère pas beaucoup de soleil
et qui en plus est non pilotable la
table c'est-à-dire par des ça arrive
comme ça décidé d'arriver donc par
définition le soleil brille la journée
la nuit c'est plus dur et le vent en
europe il passe quand il ya une
dépression et sinon il n'y a pas de vent
et c'est pas vous qui commande et les
dépressions donc le les énergies
renouvelables modernes sont plus
difficiles donc le coup il varie en
fonction de cette difficulté ou pas
extraire de l'énergie de l'environnement
donc l'énergie la moins chère
aujourd'hui et 2 très loin c'est le
kilowattheure de pétrole il faut savoir
que le coût technique d'extraction d'un
kilowattheure de pétrole d'un gisement à
terre au moyen-orient c'est une fraction
de centimes 0 3 centimes 0 3 centime
encore en face de ça le pv même à la
fameuse parité réseau
il vous en coûte 10 donc il vous en
coûte 30 fois plus et ça c'est de la
physique et on n'y peut rien alors il ya
quand même un problème concernant ces
énergies non renouvelables donc c'est
que eh bien elles s'épuisent et
aujourd'hui on parle de pic mondial en
ce qui concerne le gaz le pétrole ou
même le charbon ce sont donc les dates
auxquelles on considère qu' on a atteint
le maximum d'utilisation de ces
ressources et que par la suite elles ne
vont faire que diminuer aujourd'hui
c'est aussi quelque chose
qui me constitue une menace pour notre
système de fonctionnement de croissance
puisque nous reposons essentiellement
sur ses énergies ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire plus sur ces notions de pics de
ressources alors les combustibles
fossiles qui doivent leur nom au fait
que c'est des faux cils puisque le
charbon est un reste de végétaux qui ont
poussé il ya 300 millions d'années une
grosse fougères et le pétrole et le gaz
c'est des restes de plancton qui ont
vécu qu'avec une importe quand entre il
ya 50 millions d'années il ya 150
millions d'années
voilà donc ces combustibles fossiles ils
ont deux caractéristiques d'abord il
s'épuise effectivement parce qu'ils ont
en gros quand il faut 50 millions
d'années pour faire du pétrole ou du gaz
aux échelles de temps qui nous intéresse
les temps historiques et bien on peut
considérer qu'il n'aura pas plus entre
le début et la fin de la civilisation
industrielle de l'humanité donc plus on
tape dedans bas moins il reste ça c'est
le premier projet puis le deuxième
problème c'est qu'ils causent des
émissions de co2 et donc il cause du
changement climatique
donc en gros plus on tape vite dedans et
plus on à vis d'eux problème qui est
qu'il en reste de moins en moins et par
ailleurs on a un gros changement
climatique à gérer nous sommes en face
il y en a moins
on va donc moins maîtres de carbone donc
la question c'est est-ce que le premier
problème à régler le deuxième elle a
envie heureusement non c'est une
question de timing
absolument et de quantité parce que sur
la question climatique en fait pour
respecter l'objectif des deux degrés qui
est ce qu'on a en tête
il faut garder un chiffre en mémoire on
a encore le droit d'émettre à l'avenir
la moitié du co2 qu'on a déjà émis dans
le passé donc je prends tout le co2 que
l'humanité a émis entre 1850 et 2000 fin
2014 2015
je divise sa part 2 et c'est ce que j'ai
encore le droit d'émettre à l'avenir
alors que je m en 10 ans on me les
mettre dans 150 ans c'est une somme
beaucoup plus sombre sinon on tiendra
pas l'objectif des deux degrés et alors
ça c'est plus par an cette quantité là
c'est beaucoup moins que ce que je peux
encore extraire du sol en charbon en
pétrole et en gaz a tout de même ses
bons à oui c'est beaucoup moins
il n'empêche par contre que sur le
pétrole donc on va commencer par parler
du pétrole
le pic c'est pas un objet virtuel c'est
ce qu'on est en train de vivre en ce
moment il a été directement à l'origine
des troubles économiques qui ont démarré
aux états unis en 2006 qui ont provoqué
la chute de lehman brothers et le
pataquès financier qui a provoqué une
superbe récession en 2009 récession dont
les pays de l' ocde ne sont toujours pas
sortis puisque si vous regardez
aujourd'hui les flux physiques
la production industrielle les tonnes
kilomètres en camion
les logements construits et cetera des
pays de l' ocde ils sont globalement
sous leurs niveaux de 2007 la production
industrielle de la france et 15 % ou 10
% ça dépend de l'unité de compte qu'on
utilise sous le niveau de 2007 ceva là
c'est vrai dans tous les pays européens
grosso modo sauf en allemagne et 2 et en
pologne
même aux etats-unis ils sont tout juste
revenus à leur niveau de 2007 en
production industrielle le japon est en
dessous alors la chine est très au
dessus mais dans les pays de l' ocde
je parle bien et bel ocde on est
globalement en dessous des niveaux de
2007 donc la décroissance elle a
commencé donc on n'est pas en train de
vivre une crise en ce moment on est en
train de vivre le début d'une mutation
alors les gens le comprennent pas comme
ça donc ils pensent qu'il suffit de
faire la danse de la pluie et la
croissance reviendra malheureusement
c'est pas mon avis je pense qu'on est en
train de vivre la phase l'âge mûr on va
dire la civilisation industrielle dans
les pays de l' ocde falloir faire avec
on parlera de la cense 1 dans un autre
entretien
ceci est lié à cela cela étant alors le
déclencheur pour moi c'est le fait que
la quantité de pétrole produite dans le
monde
n'augmente plus depuis 2005 et là je
parle bien de vrais pétrole c'est à dire
ce qui sort de terre sous forme de
pétrole parce que dans les statistiques
qu'on publie petite subtilité c'est
qu'on agrège ce qui sort de terre sous
forme de pétrole avec des molécules qui
sortent de terre avec le gaz mais qui
moyennant certains traitements
deviennent liquide ne constitue pas pour
autant du pétrole et ne permettent pas
de faire ce que permet de faire le
pétrole pour être un peu plus précis on
met dedans ce qu'on appelle les liquides
de gaz des liquides de gaz c'est le
butane le propane l'éthane et le
un thann si vous êtes chauffé au gpl si
vous rouler au gpl ou si vous faites la
cuisine sur un réchaud d'une marque que
je ne nommerai pas et bien vous utilisez
ce genre de gaz mais on n'en fait pas ce
qu'on fait avec le pétrole et vous avez
également ce qu'on appelle des
condensats qui eux sont raisonnablement
proche du pétrole et qui sortent avec le
gaz
si vous regardez ce qu'il sent vraiment
sous forme de pétrole pétrole d'accord
que ce soit du pétrole de schiste ou pas
soit dit en passant est bien depuis 2005
les statistiques montrent que la
production mondiale n'augmente plus et
le miracle entre guillemets du pétrole
de schiste aux états unis il a juste
compenser le déclin qui a été
concomitant dans les autres régions du
monde
la mer du nord par exemple est en déclin
très rapide depuis l'an 2000
le bug de l'an 2000 il a vraiment eu
lieu dans la mer du nord et ça se
traduit par un déclin de 5% de la
production pétrolière de la zone tous
les ans vous avez d'autres pays qui sont
en déclin certain nombre de pays
africains sont déjà en déclin vous avez
enfin bref donc le déclin c'est un truc
est normal et au niveau mondial donc ça
n'augmente plus depuis 2005
ça va même à mon avis baisser dans les
années à venir parce que la baisse très
forte du prix du baril qu'on observe en
ce moment va diminuer les
investissements de 20 à 40 % parce que
plein de projets sont plus rentables en
et si les investissements n'ont pas lieu
alors il n'y a pas de projets
additionnels pour compenser le déclin
naturel des champs déjà en exploitation
et donc la production globale de pétrole
dans le monde devrait se tasser un peu
s'il ya moins de pétrole
il ya moins d change moins de camions
qui roulent il ya moins de voitures qui
rouillent amiens dayan qui volent et
aidera donc y aura moins de pib donc on
va on va à mon avis vers un nouveau
soubresaut dans la sphère financière
n'importe quand on entre maintenant et
trois ans donc donc ce n'est pas une vue
de l'esprit
le pic pétrolier on y est déjà
objectivement on est sur un pic très
écrasé qu'on appelle un plateau donc on
est au maximum plus ou moins quelque
chose et puis on aussi dessus et on va
continuer à osciller dessus pendant
encore quelques années je sais pas si ça
va être de 5 ou 10 et derrière la
production va se mettre à décliner pour
de bon
et que comme automobilistes je trouve ça
désagréable a malheureusement rien
changé à la faire ça va descendre il va
falloir faire avec ça va évidemment
poser un problème majeur à tous les
organismes qu'on a créé très compliqué
de se déplacer en banlieue sans voiture
très compliqué de faire tourner une
usine sans voiture sans camions etc
donc ça va poser ans pour les majeurs à
ce niveau là or le gaz
si on a comme contrainte que la géologie
serre si on dit le changement climatique
je m'en fiche
on est plutôt rendu aux alentours de
2030 et le charbon est un vrai sujet de
débat parce que les chiffres sur le
charbon sont beaucoup plus compliqués à
avoir que les chiffres sur toutes autres
formes d'énergie ils sont difficiles à
partager et j'ai tout vu entre 2020 et
2100 ça laisse une marche cela étant
même un pic charbon en 2020 c'est encore
trop tard pour tenir l'objectif des deux
degrés il ya un certain nombre de gens
pour finir là-dessus puisque nous sommes
presque en terre chinoise ici qui
pensent que l'objectif avancé par la
chine de commencer à entamer le déclin
de ses émissions en 2030 ne correspond à
rien d'autre qu'au pic de la production
de charbon en chine
dit autrement il ya des gens qui disent
ça c'est le scénario sans effort pour
eux parce que de toute façon avec les
ressources de charbon dont il dispose et
bien le pic de production du charbon il
le passe vers 2030
voilà je ne suis pas capable d'infirmer
ou de confirmer cette vision par contre
ce que je sais mon estimation c'est que
le pic de production du charbon si on a
comme seule contrainte que la géologie
il est 2005 ans plus ou moins d'un an
parce que je rappelle que la chine donc
a annoncé son pic de pollution pour 2030
oui officiellement récemment absolument
pas une bonne nouvelle absolument enfin
non c'est trop tard pour le problème
climatique il déjà mais c'était mieux
que les précédents des sérieux de dire
je m'en fiche
oui et en tout état de cause donc les
mauvaises langues
dans le milieu des géologues 10 mais
c'est juste que c'est le pic de
production de charbon gl on reparlera de
la chine plus tard et de et de ses
bonnes intentions en matière de lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique lcf
la chine en français
elles cfdt la chine en français
on va parler maintenant des énergies
renouvelables jean marc jancovici
quels sont les atouts et les faiblesses
de ces fameuses énergies renouvelables
que l'on présente parfois comme la la
solution miracle à tous nos problèmes
concernant les changements climatiques
et la pollution en général
première chose qu'il faut préciser c'est
que quand on dit énergies renouvelables
le réflexe pavlovien n'est pas le même
selon le pays dans lequel on se trouve
si vous dites énergies renouvelables
devant un norvégien il va penser
hydroélectricité oui si vous dites
énergies renouvelables devant un
islandais
il va penser géothermie et en fonction
des caractéristiques des pays dans
lesquels on retrouve si vous dites
énergies renouvelables devant un suédois
il va penser hydroélectricité et
biomasse en france
quand vont-ils éolienne énergie
renouvelable vous pensez éoliennes et
panneaux solaires et c'est aussi vrai en
allemagne je ne sais pas ce qu'il en est
aux états unis je ne sais pas ce qu'il
en est en chine
toujours est il que en france quand vous
dites donc énergies renouvelables ces
éoliennes et panneaux solaires et il est
à peu près impossible d'échapper à une
illustration soit de panneaux solaires
soit d'éoliennes quand vous avez un
article qui explique qu'il faut faire
des choses contre le changement
climatique
donc c'est vraiment devenu emblématique
alors le les énergies renouvelables ont
la caractéristique d'être comme leurs
noms l'indiquent renouvelables mais
elles ont souvent aussi la
caractéristique d'être présente dans
l'environnement
deux manières qu'il d'une telle manière
que cela ne les rend pas apte à faire
tout tout le temps n'importe comment et
pour pas cher
il ya deux énergies renouvelables qui
sont plus intéressantes que les autres
qui sont l'hydroélectricité et la
biomasse quand je dis plus intéressante
c'est économiquement pour une raison
assez simple c'est que globalement les
énergies renouvelables sont diffuses que
le vent ces tissus le soleil c'est
diffus etc
il ya deux cas de figure dans lequel la
nature a déjà fait un travail de
concentration de cette énergie diffuse
pour vous c'est soit l'hydroélectricité
parce qu'elle a prévu des vallées dans
lesquels on peut concentrer l'eau 500 ou
1000 mètres au dessus de l'endroit où on
va installer une turbine et ça s'appelle
métras de fer l'électricité en grande
quantité pour pas cher mais si vous
n'avez pas les montagnes à 1000 mètres
d'altitude au dessus enfin de la vallée
à 1000 mètres d'altitude au dessus de la
turbine si vous devez faire sa révolte
et bras musclés un ouvrage en béton qui
fait 1000 mètres de haut
ça va coûter un peu plus cher que si la
nature s'en est chargé tout seul et la
deuxième énergies renouvelables
concentré c'est le bois pour la biomasse
d'une manière générale parce que la
nature fait tout seul le travail de
photosynthèse qui consiste à prendre une
énergie très diffuses qui est l'énergie
solaire et a concentré sa dans une
énergie de stocks qui est le bois donc
les deux énergies renouvelables qui
coûtent pas cher c'est le bois et
l'hydroélectricité il soit dit en
passant quand vous regardez aujourd'hui
dans l'approvisionnement énergétique
mondial
exactement dans l'approvisionnement
énergétique des pays du monde qui a un
très fort taux de pénétration des
énergies renouvelables vous allez
trouver sans grande surprise les pays
qui ont de très grandes surfaces de
montagne par habitant et les pays qui
ont de très grandes surfaces de forêt
par habitant donc ce n'est pas un hasard
que les norvégiens 4 millions
d'habitants sur un pays qui est grand
comme la moitié ou le tiers de la france
soit les champions de l'hydroélectricité
parce qu'ils ont plein de montagne par
habitant c'est pas un hasard que les
suédois 9 millions d'habitants sur un
pays qui fait les deux tiers de la
surface française à 70% couvert de
forêts soit les champions de la biomasse
et l'hydroélectricité
c'est pas un hasard que les autrichiens
soit les champions de l'hydroélectricité
c'est pas un hasard que les brésiliens
soit les champions et est plein
d'énergie renouvelable dans le mix en
belgique
ça va être une autre paire de manches
les éoliennes si vous prenez un
justement venir
si vous prenez un pays plat et densément
peuplées donc densément peuplées pas
beaucoup de forêts plat pas beaucoup de
montagne et bien où que vous soyez dans
le monde vous allez voir son
approvisionnement en énergie
renouvelable en proportion il est très
faible
allez dire le problème est qu'à mettre
des panneaux solaires et les éoliennes
comme on a affaire à une énergie très
diffuses et qui arrivent de manière
intermittente la nuit et pas de vent
quand vous êtes en périodes
anticycloniques et bien le l'énergie aie
les diffusent
elle est intermittente et bien les
moyens qui va falloir déployer pour la
collecter la rendre utilisable et la
stocker pour les moments où elle n'est
pas disponible
environnement donc que vous ayez
toujours de l'électricité quand il fait
nuit parce que je ne va pas vous obliger
à regarder la télé quand il fait jour et
on va pas obliger les gens à prendre le
train pour rentrer chez eux
juste quand tu es du soleil aux côtés a
dit van houtte et du vin alors je crois
bien voilà faut prévoir des lits de camp
donc d'une manière générale on va avoir
besoin de la rendre utilisable
quand on pense qu'on en a besoin
donc il faut la stopper or le stockage
de l'énergie
si l'énergie n'est pas disponible sous
une forme qui s'y prête bien ça coûte un
bras l'énergie très facile à stocker
l'énergie liquid ocelot filles du
pétrole ça coûte rien fait un gros
réservoir et ça vous coûte une fraction
2% mais une fraction 2% du prix que vous
allez payer l'essence à la pompe c'est
ça vaut rien stocker du charbon c'est un
tout petit peu plus compliqué mais c'est
pas très compliqué quand même stocker du
gaz c'est un peu plus compliqué mais
c'est pas compliqué quand même non plus
tôt qu'un tas doit stocker l'électricité
c'est monstrueusement compliqué parce
que l'électricité ne se stocke pas en
tant que tel faut la transformer en
autre chose pour la stocker et cette
transformation dans un sens et dans
l'autre c'est des pertes c'est un
dispositif de stockage appropriée c'est
c'est compliqué et donc ça coûte très
cher
quand vous regardez le dans le
kilowattheure que vous allez acheter
aujourd'hui votre fournisseur
d'électricité préférez vous allez le
payer un peu plus de 10 centimes
là dans la production de l'électricité
stricto sensu ses 4,5
si vous prenez un panneau solaire que
vous mettez sur votre toit et que vous
stockée dans une batterie d'un
constructeur que je ne nommerai pas si
dans une batterie tesla et bien vous
pouvez faire un petit calcul simple le
kilowattheure va vous coûter 40 centimes
à comparer non pas aux traits ce que
vous payez quand vous l'acheter parce
que là dedans il ya du coût
d'acheminement du réseau à comparer aux
4 de coûts de production aujourd'hui en
france tout ça a coûté dix fois plus
cher et ça c'est le reflet du fait que
vous avez au départ une énergie qui est
diffuse et qui est purement électriques
dont compliqué à stocker pour les
moments où il n'y a pas de production et
vous en avez besoin quand même la
conséquence de ça c'est que si vous
regardez combien d'argent faut investir
pour produire la même quantité
d'électricité disponible à la demande
avec des moyens de type éolien ou
solaire que ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
avec des moyens dits conventionnels
alors charbon ça fait plein de co2 c'est
dégueulasse on n'en veut pas mais hydro
électricité ou nucléaires eh bien il va
falloir mettre 10 à 30 fois plus
d'argent sur la table au moment des
investissements pour avoir à l'arrivée
la même quantité d'électricité et les
ordres de grandeur sont telles que je
pense qu'il est rigoureusement
impossible de conserver la quantité
d'énergie qu'on consomme aujourd'hui en
faisant appel juste à des énergies
renouvelables de type éoliens et
photovoltaïques ne se passe pas
consommer la quantité d'électricité
qu'on consomme aujourd'hui quand vous
n'êtes pas nombreux sur un territoire où
il ya plein de montagne ça existe déjà
les norvégiens consomment deux fois plus
d'électricité par personne et par an que
les français et c'est 100% renouvelable
mais encore une fois ils sont 4 millions
de personnes sur un territoire qui fait
plus de cent mille kilomètres carrés qui
essentiellement des montagnes est tout
le problème c'est l'échelle voilà c'est
l'échelle donc tous les gens qui pensent
qu'on va conserver la civilisation
occidentale avec juste des panneaux
solaires et des éoliennes
malheureusement court derrière une
chimère ça c'est rigoureusement
impossible lcf la chine en français
lcf visite la chine en français
mais elles ont souvent aussi la
caractéristique d'être présente dans
l'environnement de manière qui ne d'une
telle manière que ça ne les rend pas
apte à faire tout tout le temps
n'importe comment et pour pas cher
il ya deux énergies renouvelables qui
sont plus intéressantes que les autres
qui sont l'hydroélectricité et la
biomasse quand je dis plus intéressante
économiquement pour une raison assez
simple c'est que globalement les
énergies renouvelables sont diffuses
levens et diffus le soleil c'est diffus
etc
il ya deux cas de figure dans lequel la
nature a déjà fait un travail de
concentration de cette énergie diffuse
pour vous c'est soit l'hydroélectricité
parce qu'elle a prévu des vallées dans
lesquels on peut concentrer l'eau 500 ou
1000 mètres au dessus de l'endroit où on
va installer une turbine et ça ça
permettra de faire de l'électricité en
grande quantité pour pas cher mais si
vous n'avez pas les montagnes à 1000
mètres d'altitude au dessus afin de la
vallée à 1000 m d'altitude au dessus de
la turbine si vous devez faire ça et vos
petits bras musclés un ouvrage en béton
qui fait 1000 mètres de haut
sarah coûter un peu plus cher que si la
nature s'en est chargé tout seul et la
deuxième énergies renouvelables
concentré c'est le bois pour la biomasse
d'une manière générale parce que la
nature fait tout seul le travail de
photosynthèse qui consiste à prendre une
énergie très diffuses qui est l'énergie
solaire et a concentré sa dans une
énergie de stocks qui est le bois donc
les deux énergies renouvelables qui
coûtent pas cher c'est le bois et
l'hydroélectricité il soit dit en
passant quand vous regardez aujourd'hui
dans l'approvisionnement énergétique
mondial
exactement dans l'approvisionnement
énergétique des pays du monde qui a un
très fort taux de pénétration des
énergies renouvelables vous allez
trouver sans grande surprise les pays
qui ont de très grandes surfaces de
montagne par habitant et les pays qui
ont de très grandes surfaces de forêt
par habitant donc ce n'est pas un hasard
que les norvégiens 4 millions
d'habitants sur un pays qui est grand
comme la moitié ou le tiers de la france
soit les champions de l'hydroélectricité
parce qu'ils ont plein de montagne par
habitant c'est pas un hasard que les
suédois 9 millions d'habitants sur un
pays qui fait les deux tiers de la
surface française à 70% couvert de
forêts soit les champions de la biomasse
et l'hydroélectricité
c'est pas un hasard que les autrichiens
soit les champions de l'hydroélectricité
c'est pas un hasard que les brésiliens
soit les champions et plein d'énergie
renouvelable dans le mix en belgique
ça va être une autre paire de manches
les éoliennes si vous prenez un
justement on va y venir
si vous prenez un pays plat et densément
peuplées donc densément peuplées pas
beaucoup de forêts plaint pas beaucoup
de montagne et bien où que vous soyez
dans le monde
vous allez voir son approvisionnement en
énergie renouvelable en proportion il
est très faible
allez dire pas de problème les cas
mettre des panneaux solaires et des
éoliennes tout comme on a affaire à une
énergie très diffuses et qui arrivent de
manière intermittente la nuit et pas de
vent quand vous êtes en période
anticyclonique et bien le d'énergie et
les diffusent
elle est intermittente et bien les
moyens qui va falloir déployer pour la
collecter la rendre utilisable et la
stocker pour les moments où elle n'est
pas disponible dans l'environnement donc
que vous ayez toujours de l'électricité
quand il fait nuit parce que va pas vous
obliger à regarder la télé quand il fait
jour et on va pas obliger les gens à
prendre le train pour rentrer chez eux
jusqu'au pied du soleil je croyais a dit
van hâu compter du 1 marche très bien
voilà faut prévoir des lits de camp donc
d'une manière générale on va avoir
besoin de la rendre utilisable
quand on pense qu'on en a besoin et donc
est vrai à stocker le stockage de
l'énergie
si l'énergie n'est pas disponible sous
une forme qui s'y prête bien ça coûte un
bras l'énergie très facile à stocker
l'énergie liquide de stocker du pétrole
ça coûte rien fait un gros réservoir et
ça vous coûte une fraction 2% mais une
fraction 2% du prix que vous allez payer
l'essence à la pompe savons rien stocker
du charbon c'est un tout petit peu plus
compliqué mais c'est pas très compliqué
quand même stocker du gaz c'est un peu
plus compliqué mais c'est pas compliqué
quand même non plus tôt qu'un d'abord y
stocker l'électricité c'est
monstrueusement compliqué parce que
l'électricité ne se stocke pas en tant
que tel faut la transformer en autre
chose pour le stocker et cette
transformation dans un sens et dans
l'autre c'est des pertes c'est un
dispositif de stockage appropriée c'est
servante compliqué et donc ça coûte très
cher quand vous regardez le
donc le kilowattheure que vous allez
acheter aujourd'hui à votre fournisseur
d'électricité préférez vous allez le
payer un peu plus de 10 centimes
là dans la production de l'électricité
stricto sensu c4 jacques si vous prenez
un panneau solaire que vous mettez sur
votre toit et que vous stockée dans une
batterie d'un constructeur que je ne
nommerai pas assis dans une batterie
tesla et bien vous pourrez faire un
petit calcul simple le kilowattheure va
vous coûter 40 centimes à comparer non
pas aux traits ce que vous payez quand
vous l'acheter parce que là dedans il ya
du coût d'acheminement du réseau à
comparer aux 4 de coûts de production
aujourd'hui en france ça a coûté dix
fois plus cher et ça c'est le reflet du
fait que vous avez au départ une énergie
qui diffuse et qui est purement
électriques dont compliqué à stocker
pour les moments où il n'y a pas de
production et vous en avez besoin quand
même la conséquence de ça c'est que si
vous regardez combien d'argent pour
investir pour produire la même quantité
d'électricité disponible à la demande
avec des moyens de type éolien ou
solaire que ce qu'on a aujourd'hui avec
des moyens dits conventionnels
alors charbon savez plein de co2 c'est
dégueulasse on n'en veut pas mais hydro
électricité ou nucléaires eh bien il va
falloir mettre 10 à 30 fois plus
d'argent sur la table au moment des
investissements pour avoir à l'arrivée
la même quantité d'électricité et les
ordres de grandeur sont telles que je
pense qu'il est rigoureusement
impossible de conserver la quantité
d'énergie qu'on consomme aujourd'hui en
faisant appel juste à des énergies
renouvelables de type éoliens et
photovoltaïques jeu ça passe par
consommer la quantité d'électricité
qu'on consomme aujourd'hui quand vous
n'êtes pas nombreux sur un territoire où
il ya plein de montagne ça existe déjà
les norvégiens consomment deux fois plus
d'électricité par personne et par an que
les français et c'est 100% renouvelable
mais encore une fois ils sont 4 millions
de personnes sur un territoire qui fait
plus de cent mille kilomètres carrés qui
essentiellement des montagnes est tout
le problème c'est l'échelle voilà c'est
l'échelle donc tous les gens qui pensent
qu'on va conserver la civilisation
occidentale avec juste des panneaux
solaires et des éoliennes
malheureusement court derrière une
chimère ça c'est rigoureusement
impossible
lcf motif la chine en français
lcf vive la chine en français
alors il ya une autre alternative bien
connu c'est le nucléaire alors c'est une
source d'énergie qui semble être une
solution mais qui est fortement décriée
du fait de sa dangerosité potentielle en
quoi c'est une solution